il est à peine 8 heures du matin et déjà
au foyer d'accueil occupationnel de la
fondation père favron en bois d'olives
les résidents se sont rassemblées sous
la varangue c'est avec le sourire et la
bonne humeur qu'ils préparent un repas
pour plus de 50 personnes car tous les
derniers jeudis du mois les résidents
qui sont concernés par la déficience
psychique de légère à sévère prépare ce
qu'ils ont baptisé leur partage une
distribution de repas pour les sans
domicile fixe à saint pierre donc on a
préparé aujourd'hui n'aurait rôti pommes
de terre tu es áfrica c'est de poireaux
voilà à la manière ancienne ont fait de
boire alors on a ceux qui sont plus à
l'aise avec le feu de bois les
ingrédients la cuisson ça fait partie de
leur apprentissage
bref à obala il ya un atelier cuisine
dont la cuisine faite de bois et donc ça
d'apprentissage et toute la semaine
qu'est ce que vous faites aujourd'hui
repas partage pour emmener les repas à
saint pierre pour les gens le dessert
n'est pas moins appétissants dans la
cuisine patricia est aux fourneaux
betty ne chôme pas elles sont guidées
toutes les deux par fabienne leur
monitrice éducatrice
elles savent normalement comme en
possède un on prépare le plan de travail
préparent tout le matériel et là on a
sur le plan de travail tout ce qu'il
nous faut on met tout en place la farine
les oeufs au chocolat et aux et ensuite
je donne des consignes pour que on peut
elle me suivre les consignes et puis on
voit la cc c'est normal c'est comme à la
maison pas
l'effort c'est pour aider les gens sont
simples sans abri qui ont et qui n'ont
rien et tout et j'aime bien aider parce
que ça me plaît parce que ils ont rien
voilà et je continuerai toujours que
tant que je serai ici
cette action a plusieurs objectifs
en plus de son utilité alimentaire et
pédagogique
elle permet aux résidents de s'inscrire
dans une utilité sociale et citoyenne de
se mobiliser autour d'une action qui a
du sens on est en difficultés pour
certaines personnes vraiment on
n'arrivait plus à à immobiliser
simplement dans les ateliers des
activités qu'on proposait parce que on
se rendait compte que ça ne parlait pas
il avait besoin de sortir utile mais
bien de se dire là quand je me lève je
vais je fais quoi pour voilà que pour
donner un sens à ma vie et ce projet-là
a fait émerger un petit peu ce sentiment
ou vraiment voilà je me lève je je
contribue à quelque chose
ils sont motivés et en donner parce
qu'ils voient effectivement hockey les
gens qui sont dans la rue qui sont sans
abri sans manger qui ne mangent pas à
leur faim et la motivation et des deux
fois plus grande effectivement donc on
le sent l'un parce qu'ils sont ils sont
prêts dès le matin de bonne heure de
diamants allez on commence par an soit
en retard
elles sont motivés parce que ici en f1
où on va dire elles ont un rythme de vie
normal je dirais et quand elle voit à
l'extérieur ce ce qui se passe elles
sont motivées et prépare ça avec
beaucoup d'entrain
2 elles sont motivées pas tout est prêt
le cari et cuits les gâteaux sortent du
four
toute l'équipe qui participent au projet
met la main à la pâte
il faut conditionner plus de cinquante
repas les charger dans le véhicule et
rouler direction la baie de saint pierre
les personnes qui ont faim sont au
rendez-vous et même un peu plus
nombreuses que le mois dernier le
surplus de repas est bienvenue ce midi
il y aura à manger pour tout le monde
merci monsieur merci monsieur
ça me touche parce que les handicapés
j'avais passé un grand bonjour je les
respecte de tout mon coeur parce que ne
l'a pas demandé comme ça et puis ce
merci à zot d'avoir préparé prévu un tir
pas aussi pour nous parce qu'il prouve à
oxala handicapés et ceux qui pensent aux
personnes que les dans la détresse les
du dans la rue je le remets à si bien et
je tiens beaucoup de chapeaux quoi ces
gens là parce que six années comme ça
les papes les passages d'auteurs non
mais si le foyer à les barbots de son
entière et tout les gens qui travaillent
à un bandeau ne pas penser un handicapé
que
et handicapées que ne proposent rien les
gens si le manger que c'est une donne
tous à la manière la manière que j'ai
kaka il ya nous tout ça ah bon madame
dali bravo ce projet est porté à la fois
par l'uefa aux de la fondation père
favron et l'association dali solidarité
c'est une réussite et tout le monde est
partant pour qu'il continue résidence en
partant pour continuer les personnes je
pense que vous les avez vus sont en
attend de nous revoir aussi des
personnes dans le besoin il faut pas les
oublier je pense que c'est important
pour les résidents aussi qu'ils voyent
ce qui a en dehors de l'institution
au-delà du projet d'établissement au
delà des valeurs aussi comme un niveau
de la fondation des projets qu'on peut
faire au niveau des résidents voilà
qu'ils oublient pas qu'ils sont faux
mais il ya aussi
ce qui se passe à l'extérieur et c'est
important qu'ils qu'ils en aient
conscience qu'ils sabrent s'il 68e les
résidents sont rentrés chez eux au foyer
d'accueil à leur tour maintenant
apprécier ce déjeuner qui après une
matinée chargée en émotion à une toute
autre saveur